- Hey guys, what's up,
I'm Hanna Dickinson
and I'm here hangin' and
bangin' at Clusterfest.
I'm just looking for
good food, fun times,
and creative ways to
disappoint my parents.
(party music)
Hey what's up,
I'm here with Ben.
I actually slept
with a Ben last year
who never called me back,
so why do you think that is?
- Did you tell
him your real name
or did you use the fake
name that you told me
just before we
started filming this?
- And what name was that?
- Bovis?
- So are you single, what's up?
- I am not single.
- What do you do?
- Finance for a tech company.
- No, that sounds great for me.
How much money do
you make a year?
- I can't count
that high, honestly.
- Are you single?
- No.
- You guys, we need
to screen these people
before we talk to them.
- Are you single,
what's happening?
- No.
- What does your girlfriend do?
- I'm not straight.
- So what's up Steph?
- Hungover.
- Are you dating anyone?
- No.
- That is a yes.
- Are there any comedians
here you wanna make out with?
- A few.
Are they gonna watch this,
I don't wanna say the name.
- Jon Stewart?
- No, Nick Kroll.
- He's definitely
not watching this.
- Yeah I know.
- I'm here with very
funny comedian Ali Siddiq.
How are you doing?
- I'm doing magnificent.
- Ooh, that's nice.
- I'm gonna say a bunch
of weird stuff tonight.
- What do you
consider weird stuff?
'Cause I say a
lot of weird shit.
- But I don't like having
sex with pregnant women.
- I don't think
that that's weird.
I think that might
be a universal,
I don't know if we're
allowed to say that.
- There's a lot of
men who like sleeping
with pregnant women.
- Well I look pregnant
after a full meal, so,
that's a turn on for me.
- No, I would have sex
with a slightly full woman.
I mean, we've eaten, and now
we're trying to exercise.
- So have you guys
ever had a threesome?
- No.
Yeah, no.
- That was like a nervous one,
like you have definitely
fallen into one.
I've been kicked
out of a threesome.
It's a long story.
I'm actually here
with Action Bronson.
- My name's Rusty.
- So what do you
do for a living?
- I'm retired.
- What did you do before?
- I actually was a cook.
- Does chef mean you deal drugs?
- Um, no, I'm on drugs.
- Are you single,
or what's happening?
- Very single.
- That sounds like
an invitation for me.
- Do you both work in tech?
- I work 100% in tech.
- You look like a guy
who works in tech.
How much money do you guys make?
(both laugh)
- I make tech money.
- Yeah but I don't
know what that means.
I make digital money.
- Enough to live
in San Francisco.
- Ooh all right.
What about you?
- I don't make tech money.
- What do you do,
are you a barista?
- No, a little bit
better than that.
- Urban Outfitters?
What do you do?
- I work for the city.
- That's worse than
Urban Outfitters.
(laughing)
Where's your girlfriend,
I don't see her?
- She goes to a
different school.
- How long have you
guys been together?
- What time is it?
- Ooh, is that my window?
- You might have a little
window of opportunity here.
- I mean, girl's revenge
is always the worst,
you know what I mean?
I'm not looking to get
chopped up into little pieces.
Do you guys have sunscreen on?
I can tell you're a
ginger, you might need it.
- I don't, no.
- What part of your body would
you like to be rubbed down?
Or I mean, protected?
Sorry.
- Just my neck and arms for now
'cause I'm pretty
covered otherwise.
- All right, can we get some...
I'm really good with my hands.
I don't know, it's weird.
Do you wanna try to pick me up?
Wow!
- Yo, me and Hanna are out.
(drum and keyboard hit)